good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday oh my
god it's hump day both the streis
brothers are in the building first time
together the four of us iconic foursome
at the studio hey jax how you doing i'm
doing very well because it is hum day
the streis brothers are here to
celebrate and name a more iconic
foursome you couldn't you can no like
you could try you could try
dario
right like we said no more iconic
foursome than bryce thrice and their
parents we are here with both the boys
it's wednesday this is our third episode
in your new studio today your tech
director iv girl no not ivy
av girl
is praying for no technical difficulties
today i think today's the day third
time's the charm as they say there's
some lessons us av girlies need to learn
the hard way like you have to initialize
your memory cards who the [ __ ] knew that
you know we have someone who helps us at
our studio in new york so all of this is
new to me um so i'm hoping i have no
hard lessons to learn today that's my
goal
my goal is also never leave the backup
memory card slot empty why not like why
the [ __ ] would you do that dumb [ __ ]
i think their time's gonna be the charm
yesterday's audio was so premium and
then it was the video that crapped out
and so today
we're gonna be firing in all cylinders
unfortunately the streis brothers are no
help whatsoever because they don't have
thumbs and they don't get their [ __ ]
asses up at work look at them sleeping
on the job you know that's what you get
with the morning toast like these people
who have weekly podcasts like you never
really know the ins and outs the av
the tech the ivy
and with the morning toast since we're
so transparent consistent and authentic
like you're seeing all sides of the
podcast making and i feel like after the
toasters listen to every episode this
week by friday afternoon you should be
able to make your own in-home studio and
produce a premium podcast that's what
you learn here that is what you learn
and we're going to give you all that
industrial
entrepreneurial spirit and
industrialization industrial that we
love to foster right we foster at the
morning toast chosen news network in
entrepreneurial spirit and i used to
think that being an entrepreneur meant
you didn't have a job um but i've
actually changed my mind on that it is
one of those terms that could go either
way you could be an entrepreneurial you
could be a big success a big wig or you
could be unemployed and an aspiring
bigwig yeah like i think when a lot of
people go on dating apps and someone's
job is listed as entrepreneur like it's
a potential red flag yeah there are a
lot of
terms and titles that
could be
bigwig or no wig crypto is one of them
crypto oh i
since i don't know anything about crypto
i know it gets a really bad rap but i'm
interested by it like if i went on a
date with someone who worked in crypto
like i would ask a lot of questions no
but if like you were scrolling on
someone's profile and it was like job
crypto minor i would be like you either
live in a mansion or on the street you
know i would assume they're a
billionaire yeah well not anymore but
this right bitcoin's crashing another
department that's like that is real
estate like if you are in real estate
you're either a mogul or an aspiring
mogul also speaking of moguls and
billions um i had a major announcement i
wanted to share because i was talking a
lot on the podcast yesterday and on my
instagram that i had bought um 60 worth
of lottery mega millions tickets and i
haven't really told everyone whether i
won yet so um special announcement
breaking news i um lost and you should
know that because i'm here and if i had
won 830 million dollars last night like
no offense i would not be here but you
won some money right or was that a joke
oh that was a joke oh didn't know i
literally hate you okay so at 11 me
olivia
zack and ben were up watching and we all
went in on the lottery together you and
your husband olivia and her husband and
me and myself that is writing a ponzi
scheme i was right i was running you're
welcome by the way because like if we
had one it would have been on me i
thought we did win i have to tell my
husband he was like already spending his
oh my god so at 11 15 i wrote in our
little lottery chat jackie wasn't at the
house with us i was like oh my god you
guys like we obviously didn't win the
830 but i had like the mega ball number
and two other numbers and we literally
won fifty seven thousand dollars i came
up with the most oh my god by the way we
haven't even spoken about this this
morning you believed me a hundred
percent and then i responded in the chat
zach and i were arguing because he was
like i was like did you send the money
because she won and he was like yeah and
i was like okay great so
we'll probably wind up with around like
6k and he's like great i could do my
closet and i was like well we have to
split that right and he was like well i
sent the money and i was like no you
sent it for the both of us i was like i
need to get clarity from claudia if the
20 was per couple or per person per
couple right so we were already oh my
god by the way i'm cracking up that you
guys believed me because i was working
my texts were really convincing with the
typos and the all caps right yeah no i
didn't even question it like you 156k
where are we spending it on claude you
didn't answer
i figured like i would get a phone call
this morning i figured that you didn't
answer like you knew i was just making
[ __ ] up no i i saw it i was excited and
i put my phone back down and i was like
okay you're being so weird and low-key
if you had one fifty seven thousand
dollars in the lottery it would have
called six of us one fifty thousand
seven thousand dollars it's about 25k
divided by
three no i get it when you boil it down
but the concept of winning fifty seven
thousand dollars is huge i would have
called you yeah but i knew i was seeing
you this morning like we would talk
about on the show everyone would be so
excited for you you're so weird i was
totally kidding so much going on and i
think i saw it like in the middle of uh
sleep in the middle of the night when i
was like checking on harry so i wasn't
like trying to
get all amped up i was like
earning school
oh my god i cannot believe my prank
worked i'm literally quaking and i'm
quaking at how like low-key you're being
about it it's really weird i'm extremely
low-key you are you are like you're just
i guess fifty-seven thousand dollars is
not a lot to you well divided by 2
divided by 6. um
but also that's just something about me
like when something's a big deal good or
bad i don't process it it's true and i
don't make a big deal out of it and it's
not until years later i'm like wow that
was a really big deal no i like i'm a
drama queen like i make everything a
moment you know yeah um so no we won
literally zero dollars damn and i just
feel like i'm back i'm doing this closet
oh man i cannot believe zach thought i
won well he's with ben now so probably
they'll get to that conversation at some
point right i hope so well the thing
with the mega millions is by the way
nobody won last night now the jackpot
that's being drawn on friday is over a
billion dollars um so of course we will
be going to publix and getting more
tickets let me know if you want in on my
podcast
uh yeah well i'm gonna come to publix
with you okay um which is just like a
fun experience for us anyway like being
at publix totally maybe i need to wear
pants because i'm freezing and the
grocery store is cold maybe we'll vlog
it yeah i was saying we need to do a pub
sug mukbang but then you were being
toxic about your diet yeah no i'm
toxic but you are by the way like you're
the person that you hate yeah i know i
just want you to know so like next time
and every time in my life that i've ever
you know given you know had to be like
oh no like calories or i'm gonna die
whatever like you've given me so much
[ __ ] not being supportive whatsoever no
not at all and i hope maybe you'll think
twice next time no i won't because i
feel like when you just expect everyone
to be on your wavelength no no no when
you give me [ __ ] about like me being on
a diet right now um i can't lie like i
do feel superior so if i've made you
feel that way you're welcome and second
of all i will do the pub sub today
because i actually am starving and three
like i cannot stress this enough that
this is like a temporary mindset for me
like i will be back to my normal self in
like probably a few months yeah but you
know what do what you got to do and i
mean i just want to get down to like a
healthy weight i'm not trying to be a
model i i really believe that like the
the
what's what is it like the conversation
about dieting has gotten a little too
out of control and i agree you can go on
a diet agreed it's not
a cancelable investment and she could go
on a diet and that doesn't mean that you
have to go on a diet and just because
i've chosen to go on a diet does not
mean that i think you should go on a
diet or that anyone else should and i'm
not influencing anyone it's just like my
body and i'm choosing to do
less with it honestly or more however
you want to look at it yeah um but it's
definitely like a temporary thing i just
feel like i like to you know my weight
fluctuates always but i would like a
more healthy starting point for when i
start to eat like an animal again you
know yeah i'm sure that's not healthy
and it's toxic but like i just
um it is what it is i'm getting like out
of breath just doing menial things you
know and i feel so much better i'm like
not so sluggish no one it's like every
picture you take it's like gorgeous you
don't have to sweat it i'm not worried
about angles on the show i'm like you
don't have to worry about your angles
anymore that doesn't really um hurt i
can't lie you know everyone telling me i
look so great but it's like why weren't
you telling me it looked great when i
was about actually that's not true
people did but you know it feels
different yeah because you're working
for it and yeah i feel like hard work is
paying off yeah totally um so that's
enough about me in my toxic diet culture
but i think i'm ready for a pub sub
sounds good i feel like i'm almost ready
to re-enter toxic uh not toxic diet
culture but like not eating everything
inside anymore do you think that you
have um had diet toxic diet tendencies
yeah yeah yeah have i not never copped
to that no well i mean i know you do but
i don't know if we ever actually know i
feel like everyone's always yelling at
me like what i say
i can't do the toxic dieting thing one
because i'm too hungry too because i'm
breastfeeding so i actually like need
nutrition
and all that and it's also like
unsustainable but i just like want to
start making healthier choices whereas
and i actually i'm feeling like being
down here and being like in the suburbs
and also walking around my house like
i'm taking so many more steps my aura
ring is like
girl go for it oh
having like an actual kitchen where you
can like store fresh produce prepare
things yeah no there's definitely a
healthier vibe here in the city it's
like you eat for convenience yeah no and
that's really what i was doing so
now i'm ready to like to put a little
more effort into making better choices
speaking of breastfeeding i had a really
interesting conversation with olivia
this morning because we were talking
about um
you know where i don't even want to say
it like we're creeping on yom kippur
the time of year where we have to fast
um and i was like you know what i don't
know how long jackie's planning on
breastfeeding for but like she should
just keep going so she doesn't have to
fast and olivia is like if you're
breastfeeding you still have to fast did
you know that where does it say that
olivia literally spoke to a rabbi nicky
about it like when when she was pregnant
and breastfeeding well i do plan on
still being breastfeeding by then um it
would have just been a perk to not have
to fast
we'll see and that's just a jewish
principle i take umbrage with honestly
like the fasting or the breastfeeding in
fact the rest of the fasting of course
but i understand it's atonement for our
sins and i definitely should participate
but not supporting breastfeeding mamas
mamas
get them i don't support her yeah i'm
sure you could find like different
rabbis who have different that's the
thing about judaism though it's it's
interesting
but like with the rabbi that we love and
respect that's what he said so i guess
we gotta find another rabbi
yeah i feel like i would try to fast and
then if it was too hard
you know i would see how it goes i would
wait and see because we love doing that
because it's so important to see
only after waiting and i can't stress
that enough
yeah um the other thing i wanted to talk
about is it's wednesday which means
tonight we are doing an episode of
breaking bread and i just wanted to
remind everyone since we were off last
week while jackie was moving breaking
bread is back tonight 7 p.m eastern time
4 p.m pacific time on the spotify live
app if you download the app you can join
the show live you can write in the
comments section which is really more
entertaining than the show honestly yeah
um you can get brought up on stage
listen to your girlies just recap we
actually will have so much to talk about
on breaking bread tonight because i feel
like the last three days every time we
rap like we still have more to talk
about so it'll be really fun you can
also listen live on just the regular
spotify app but you won't be able to
like you know be a real integral part of
the show like with the comment section
and stuff and if you're unavailable
tonight wednesday 7 p.m eastern time our
episodes do go on demand onto spotify on
friday so there's fun for the whole
family
totally
and that's just a little bit about me
you covered the whole gamut what else is
new with you well how's bryce how's
rolled everything is good just so busy i
mean every day just doing a million
things uh do you want to interject sorry
yeah i wanted to tell you something
i um i started the hotel nantucket i saw
tell me everything um it's really good
it's just like i've been in such a rut
reading like you know erotic romances
that i love so much um but i thought i
would like you know pull back
branch out and so it's taking an
adjustment to read something different
but also i've never read a book with a
ghost in it and like i'm not a spooky
girl i'm not into like paranormal
activity some people's like whole
personalities being like obsessed with
ghosts and like cemeteries and ouija
boards um that's not me but um i kind of
like
love this ghost she's not like other
ghosts no she's like a cutie she's like
an unhinged 19 year old right
with the wisdom because she's 100 years
yes but she died when she was 19. how
what percent are you at you read so fast
i don't know actually i didn't read a
lot last night honestly i could not
focus on anything but the lottery what
happened so far where are you at has the
hotel opened yeah yeah yeah they just
started spoiler alert getting bad
reviews on um like tripadvisor oh okay
cute yeah no the ghost is really cute
and she adds like a fun flavor i'm
typically not a ghost girly but i'm
always open to it if you read layla by
colleen hoover i actually have it it's
another ghost tale and throughout the
book i was like what the [ __ ] but then
by the end it made sense it made sense
and i love when things make sense
yesterday i started the new redheads
book a flicker in the dark and it is
spooky but so well written but it's just
like gives you chills i just gotta chill
out my spine yeah maybe grace
grace is working the ac i also can't
stress enough how much i'm loving the
kindle oasis like it is that kindle you
need it like and if you didn't get it on
prime day i feel bad for you because
it's [ __ ] expensive and i saved like
over 100 on it but it's so premium like
if you ever kindle girly and you're
still with that
my now that i realize
how fabulous this new one is i realized
how slow my old one was you want to
write colleen hoover
c
oh
and now i'm like colleen over it's so
premium it's like technology as an i i
why can't i say av
i don't know you have an aversion
technology as an av girl is like so
important to me you know totally and i'm
enjoying the oasis life as well i wasn't
ready for it
ago but i'm ready for it now i'm loving
those little buttons question for you do
you have your what do you use the up and
down for like down pay like
do you use the down button for the next
page or the up button excuse me i can
change it yeah because obviously i was
like the down one should go right
because it's closer to my thumb and when
i open the kindle it was just like you
have to use the top one i reprogrammed
mine a few days ago
you need a v assistant oh my god
i was thinking how stupid that was i'm
like if i had to guess a million dollars
obviously the one closer to my thumb is
going to be next what am i reading a
book backwards yeah oh my god you just
blew my mind yeah thank you so much i'll
show you how to do that you're that's
what i'm here for we're literally like
tekken
yes
we're technologists no like elon musk
literally wishes he knew much about
technology as we do
he almost wishes he could reprogram his
kindle no i'm like literally embarrassed
for him for how little he knows compared
to us it's like so sad
beyond
beyond
oh we also dear toasters today oh wow
and they're pretty wild honestly like oh
i cannot wait we have so much to do
should we just get into it i mean i
wouldn't i really wouldn't be against it
okay and you know things come up along
the way and we'll chat here and there
about ourselves so without further ado
where are you
strikes brothers are here his aunties
where are you the streis brothers are
here sleeping
where are you
i took theo for a walk this morning and
he made the biggest dump i've ever
seen a a human being or a dog make i
meant to tell you did he have anything
extra was it just been like did he have
a tbt well actually um
he has cornered taylor
i'm literally having a stroke today
cornered kaler
every time kayla has a snack it's in
theo's mouth and she's just started to
give it to him like she's submissive
like at first she used to fight and now
she just gives it he's been eating so
much off the floor i've been giving him
treats like when him and burner together
i'm always giving them greenies so he's
definitely eating a lot more which i'm
not mad about but um it's coming out in
his poop i could not believe the poop i
almost vomited bruno is also eating a
lot more he indulged in a turkey
sandwich the other night that sounds
good last night i found him going
through the trash he found himself an
apple
and just other miscellaneous things i'm
happy for these dry sprouts the suburbs
are treating them well
the suburbs are treated i mean look at
them
pooped pooped
so did you do the crunch no i don't
think so without further a do it is time
for the pastor's story
where are you
it is time for the past life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
bowling branch bowling branch uses the
best hundred percent organic
organic cotton threads on earth
for superior softness and a better
night's sleep their sheets aren't just
buttery breathable and impossibly soft
to start they get softer with every wash
you know i come on here once a week and
rave about bowling branch about how i
literally can't sleep anywhere but my
bed and you guys are gonna be like
claudia like well how are you staying at
olivia's house for so long homegirl has
bowling branch because she's a woman of
taste a woman of elegance and honestly
i've been sleeping like just as good you
know i have to tell you i had a fright
in the middle of the night last night
but had nothing to do with bowling
branch you had to do with the book i was
writing got it well i also have bowling
branch sheets on my guest bed for you
the signature sheet the competition
continues and
i just want you to know that bowling
branch signature sheets which is what i
have i think it's what olivia has too
it's what you have the signature sheet
collection come in nine different colors
they're all neutral they come in all
sizes from twin up to california king
and you will immediately feel the
difference of their iconic signature
sheets 100 free from toxins which means
no pesticides formaldehyde or harsh
chemicals and they give you a 30 night
risk free trial so with free shipping
and no returns on all orders they're so
sure you're going to love it and so am i
so you can also get 20 off site-wide
during the annual summer event happening
now only at bowlingbranch.com it's their
best offer of the year before the
holidays so you better act now that's
bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch dot com for 20 off
site wide today's episode is also
brought to you by legacy box the
simplest and safest way to digitize all
of your aging video tapes camcorder
tapes film wheels and pictures so they
are preserved forever this is probably
the number one brand people dm like what
was that company what was your code
just listen you can buy the service now
and send it in when you're ready but if
you want to use our code i would suggest
doing it now
we've done it you know we were
brought up in the vhs era and a couple
years ago we used to like buy all this
weird equipment that didn't work just in
an attempt to actually watch our vhs
because we obviously didn't have a vhs
machine and legacy box digitizes
everything by hand home movies you can
transport
yourself back to those unforgettable
times so each item is hand digitized by
a team of over 200 trained technicians
in tennessee each kit includes
everything you need to safely pack and
send your recorded moments including
safety stickers for every item they've
been trusted by over a million families
they are the industry leader in
professionally digitizing family
memories they can digitize 19 different
types of media so we obviously did vhs
tapes they can do super 8 film they can
do pretty much anything you got so take
advantage of this exclusive offer today
and then use your legacy box whenever
you're ready again don't message me it's
right here that's legacybox.com
toast to save 40 off legacybox.com
toast
legacy box dot com slash toast take
advantage of the limited time offer of
40 off and then discover the magic of
bringing your past back to life
great thank you so much it's a pleasure
our first story chris rock is setting
the record straight on the will smith's
oscar slap he says i'm not a victim okay
chris rock has finally broken his
silence regarding the slap hurt around
the world yeah that [ __ ] hurt
[ __ ] but i shook that [ __ ] off
and went to work the next day after
remaining silent mostly silent for
months the comedian actor addressed
getting smacked by will at the oscars he
said quote anyone who said words hurt
has never been punched in the face he
declared while performing alongside
kevin hart and dave chappelle at msg on
saturday oh my god that actually sounds
so fun obviously like the one time i'm
not in new york thanks also during the
event kevin hart brought a live goat on
stage and introduced it as will smith
oh my god
um entertainment experience in the
tri-state area and he said i'm not a
victim [ __ ] i don't go to the
hospital for a paper cut no no um
it's just you know what i didn't expect
i didn't expect to like be so into chris
rock you know i think we all like had a
soft spot in our hearts for him after
this lap because it was so [ __ ] crazy
and it was so
like embarrassing and painful for
everyone um and then the like bell of it
all and i just like i didn't expect to
be so like into him you know like
intrigued by what's chris doing what's
chris saying
what's chris up to what's chris feeling
like more of a chris jenner girl than a
chris rock but
that might change that might change the
show looks amazing dave chappelle chris
rock and kevin hart i mean what a line
up i've actually never seen any of chris
rock's stand up but it's like ben's
favorite ben is chris rock's number one
fan oh that's nice yeah um i don't know
if they're like doing a tour together or
it was like a one-time thing at msg but
if any of you guys were there who are
listening i'm so jealous that sounds
amazing
literally amazing i saw kevin hart at ms
she how was it it was great he i was the
most people ever fit into msg because
like he had a teenager
he had a teeny tiny stage in the middle
and they were able to put as many seats
as they've ever put in there how many
shows did he do
i'm not sure i just went to one that's
cool i would want to see him do stand up
he's so funny for so long he was my
absolute favorite comedian and stand-up
comedian yeah he's great but then he was
usurped by claudia ashrae
oh that reminds me tickets available at
girlsnojob.com tour west hampton beach
new york red bank new jersey new haven
connecticut more dates coming soon um i
added a another show i was thinking like
gotta get to alabama
i want the alabama girls to like know
i'm coming bama bama roll tide i'm
literally gonna be like such an alabama
girl like war eagle
what's that oh my god okay so i
obviously you wouldn't know that because
is it from tick tock no no because
you've never been to alabama and i only
learned it the first time i went got it
obviously when i went i was like roll
tide like whatever the [ __ ] that means
and like
it's half and half so there's two
schools auburn and university of alabama
university of alabama is world tied and
auburn is war eagle so like whichever
your fri your school is like that's the
phrase you stick with okay so you're war
eagle i'm roll tide no i didn't say that
um
i was just teaching i think i'm rolled
tied i'm definitely rolled tied
probably i'm definitely roll doll tied
so you're an anti-semite
yikes
honestly i just want to let you know if
you've ever like dm'd me or left a
comment that starts with yikes or ends
with yikes like you will be black we're
include yikes in the middle because
people who say yikes on the internet in
like an ironic derogatory ironic way
like yeah we say it like making fun of
those people but the people who use it
in their everyday karen energy are the
worst people on the internet i literally
like screenshotted a message the other
day it was so
[ __ ] condescending like
yikes it was about the couch he was like
chill the [ __ ] out
yikes you guys have lost your touch that
couch i'm like you're [ __ ] ugly okay
i want to see your couch yeah facetime
me
yikes
i hate the word yikes so much
me too yes
and it comes with that face you know
yikes
[Laughter]
if you've ever said that like you're
done you're done
okay well are you ready for our next
story why not because there's drama
between candace cameron beret and jojo
siwa i saw cameras town candace cameron
bray is addressing jojo siwa calling her
the rudest celebrity in a tick tock
video she said now it is all good but
for those of us who are just hearing the
news for the first time such as myself
jojo posted a video to her social media
platform showing her quickly flashing
photos of celebrities so let me tell you
it's a trend on tickets that i've i've
surmised okay so for those who don't
know let me just say yeah yeah you
basically pull up different people's
instagram profiles on your phone and
then you write you take a video of
yourself and you write like
you know worst hookup i ever had and
then you flash the phone really quick
and some people have been able to like
slow down the video screen record them
and figure out who people are but like
if you do it really fast there's like
actually no way to see it so it's like
worse hook up you know celebrity i have
the most tea on you know rudest person
i've ever met and other influencers and
celebrities are doing it to each other
and i i cannot tell you how many times i
have literally downloaded the person's
tic talk and scrolled through to try and
like screen record it's so hard to
figure out but somebody figured out
jojo's i saw they do edit it and showed
every single person that she did wow
okay so she did the nicest the coolest
her crush and she also did the rudest
and flash the phone to reveal candace
cameron beret she didn't provide any
further details about their alleged
interaction but now candace cameron
beret is i'm just gonna have to call her
candy yes it's a lot 100
who has taken her instagram saying that
she was shocked and had no idea where it
came from she said i immediately tried
to reach out to her through mutual
friends and my publicist contacted her
manager and i dm'd her because i didn't
know what happened i just it's funny
that candace cameron beret and jojo siwa
have mutual friends oh i'm sure
like i just find that interesting yeah
she said so i was finally able to talk
to jojo this morning i called her and we
had a great conversation she was like
hey how are you doing i was like well
i've been better what happened
so jojo told
candice that she didn't think her video
was going going to go viral calling it a
silly tick-tock trend and saying that
she didn't think it was a big deal but
then candace told her that it was a big
deal and asked her what she did to her
i'm sure she was like getting dragged to
filth to filth
because candace said i only remember
that we met at the kelly clarkson show
and that went really great and that's
iconic jojo said yeah it was really
great you were super nice and all of
that she actually didn't want to tell me
because she said it's so silly she felt
bad and that's why it just wasn't a big
deal to her but then she said i met you
at the fuller house premiere when i was
11 years old and we were all on the red
carpet i'd come up to you and said can i
have a picture with you and you said to
me not right now then you proceeded to
do what you were doing and take pictures
with other people on the red carpet so
candace profusely apologized to jojo and
jojo said you weren't even mean they get
it now as an adult when you're on the
red carpet and everything's happening
you're being pulled in different
directions but at that time i wasn't
going to love it i was 11. and then
candace apologized saying i broke your
11 year old heart i didn't take a
picture with you i feel so sorry
and crummy
and now there's been a rep more
here are words that i literally never
thought would come out of my mouth ever
like just as for candace cam and beret
like sounds like jojo's he was being
like a big [ __ ] starter and like when
she was like no i don't even want to say
what it is it was giving um crystal kung
mink off
like
sutton said the craziest thing so
offensive dark what is it i can't say it
so first of all i'm always doubtful when
people say that
and second of all
literally if
if that's what happened everything jojo
just described uh
that's really not rude and it doesn't
sound like a consistent story because
why would candace kamen beret take
pictures with a bunch of people on a red
carpet and not jojo siwa like
when she was 11 like fans yeah no she
was she was probably a celebrity
like mom's yeah just a kid celebrity um
i agree i mean it's really a nothing
burger it just goes to show that every
other celebrity must be you know the
nicest person on the planet right if
that's the worst thing that happens
but what candace cameron murray said is
that no matter how many followers you
have even a 10 second trending tick tock
video can do damage because our words
matter and our actions matter and that's
the thing it's like so much of tick tock
is just putting people on blast both you
know probably righteously and also in a
shit-starting sort of way and i really
feel like that people have really made
like careers of just like trolling and
and calling people out and blowing
things out of proportion like that
instacart driver who said he made kylie
right gave kylie the ingredients for her
sandwiches like right everyone's just
like everyone like sharing their story
like i saw this celebrity one time and
she was so rude like you don't know what
someone else is going through like you
only see things like through your
perspective and it's like
and then you say it as fact and people
run with it because like it's fun for
them right no but honestly this is like
like kind of extremely illusory of
jojo's i'm i'm really shocked because
first of all
it doesn't sound like there was really
like an incident and then also the way
candace describes the phone call it's
like jojo got like like called out like
yeah there was nothing there yeah
she now she is she must be 18 right
now she's grown she is
give me one second 19. oh wow okay so
she's like
she's still like a kid but like she
should know better like as a celebrity
to start dumb drama like this like
yeah but that's the trend and that's
what i'm saying like it's toxic and
people are just obsessed with like call
out culture getting famous and getting
views because they're putting
they're
embarrassing someone else no i
completely agree with you oh great we're
on the same page are we ever known
no except about tick tock and olivia
rodrigo being a one hit wonder
i never said she was one wonder i said
it was too soon to call sure
no that's what i said like i stand by
that sure
oh this microphone brand is sure
s-h-u-r-e so
sure
that's my joke i was the one walking
around guitar center saying sure
sure you were
i missed guitar center
let's go back you know i think
we need headphones for that we do do we
have to go to guitar center i think we
do oh my god i think we do they'll be so
happy to see us my day just blew wide
open they're gonna say hey girlies how
was the equipment and i was like oh hey
you listen to yours listen to me myself
corporate hasn't called you yet because
literally the biggest podcast in the
world
reference your amazing customer service
i figured you'd be the president of the
company by now no i would say to him why
don't you go to your apple podcasts go
to the comedy chart is that what you're
doing yeah and why don't you go to
episode number
seven we were six yesterday oh we're
seven and eight right now we are
literally like chart topping top
charting i'm so cute seven and eight we
are so cute we are so cute like who's
cuter funnier more interesting than us
we should go i'll give you a minute
nobody the strict brothers oh [ __ ] yeah
you should go to guitar center when our
episode is like as high as it's going to
be so it's that six or five yeah okay
and then wait for them to be like how
did it go oh oh i just happened to bring
my ipad with a screenshot of the chart
if you want to know you want to check it
out
check it out are you ready for our next
story only if it's a story that's
brought to you by away it is it actually
really is because it's some airport
drama right no and it's so appropriate
because the last time i was at olivia's
house i had to leave my black carry-on
away suitcase at her house and that was
literally six months ago and i haven't
gotten it back and it has been like like
made like a visible impact on my life
not having my suitcase away offers a
range of suitcases bags and other travel
essentials made of different materials
like polycarbonate and aluminum in a
variety of colors and sizes so whatever
you're packing wherever you're going
away has a luggage that will help you
make your next trip more seamless
they've got four wheels they've got hard
shells they've built in laundry bags
they come with like a little magic
eraser so anytime you know a bag handler
is like a little too rough a little
scuff it out oh have you seen those
videos they're extremely rough these
days they're insane so
travel is so uncertain but the one thing
we can be certain of is like a ways
suitcases bags and travel accessories
are designed to make moving through the
world a lot more seamless travels makes
us more you know more dynamic more
interesting and it gives us different
perspectives so no matter where you're
going you can rely on a ways range of
travel products to solve real travel
problems and get you there so it's a tsa
approved bag they have that combination
lock that is totally tsa approved they
have four 360-degree spinner wheels
which makes it so easy to what were
people doing before four 360-degree
spinner wheels especially in um excuse
me carpeted airports i am embarrassed to
say i have a few pieces of luggage still
for when i need like backup backup that
are on two wheels and like using those
while i'm pushing my away it's just like
the past and the future they offer free
shipping and returns on any order within
u.s europe canada and australia except
for the personalized products and they
have 100 day free trial on everything
that they make so you take the product
on the road you live with it you travel
with it even get lost with it for a
hundred days and then if you decide it's
not for you you can return any
non-personalized item for a full refund
during that period no ifs ands or bots
so get your 100 day trial started and
shop the entire away lineup of travel
essentials including their best-selling
suitcases and bags at away travel dot
com slash toast that's away travel dot
com
i just bought new away suitcases i love
my pink ones and i was using them and i
actually needed more because i was
moving and we just have and also like
traveling with a baby like you just need
tons of crap so i bought the biggest bag
and the medium-sized bag in that dark
green and so it's like i have my green
bags and my pink bags and so toasty so
i have my toast stickers like all over
myself i have my uh limited edition camp
toast luggage tags
if you know you know
next story some airport news brought to
you by way erica jane served with a 50
million lawsuit upon returning home from
a lux hawaii vacation
following her lux trip to hawaii erica
jane was served with papers for a 50
million racketeering lawsuit when she
arrived back in
l.a on friday night in exclusive picks
obtained by
page six the real housewives of beverly
hills star was seen leaving la
international airport when a woman
approached her and handed her two thick
stacks of documents a rep for erica's
did not immediately respond to a request
for comment someone was videoing and
it's honestly like it's mortifying to
see yeah but what i also thought was
really interesting was that she was on
vacation in hawaii with rena and diana
so why was she at lax
like wouldn't they have flown private
hawaii yeah mla with diana right that is
interesting i also just thought it was
interesting that the three of them were
hanging out off
but that traffic
i mean i'm so behind on beverly hills
like
i haven't turned a tv don't even have a
tv right now um so i don't know what's
going on but like renanda seems like uh
i mean diana seems well her and renault
close yeah um the video is horrifying
and it's like so embarrassing because
i'm sure like at first erica thinks it's
like a fan maybe wanting an autograph or
just like you know people do crazy
things to public figures um and i think
like you see the moment where it settles
that she's like being and you know it
was legit because it had one of those
paper clips not like a classic paper
clip the one that's like a clam of
course because it's so many documents
because it was like this big thick stack
and it was just like
honestly it actually made me feel bad
for her because it was just really
embarrassing with so many cameras around
him renault was like why were there so
many cameras around because you know
those girlies love to call the paps on
themselves do you think they called the
paparazzi on themselves for sure
you think so i don't think the paparazzi
like
really really needs ever you know erica
and rina getting off a plane like if
they were there it's because you know
they call them so they called them and
then it's like she got served like i
just think if erica wanted to go on a
trip fly home commercial like she could
make it through the airport without
paparazzi that's what i'm saying so i
think it's like so weird
that oh you think it had something to do
with the serving i don't know and some
of the pictures are clearly like an
iphone situation yeah the video that
went viral that started the story was
someone just filming i think on their
iphone like a fan saw eric at the
airport perhaps
or was it someone who like they the part
of the people who served her just to
confirm that they served her
i just think it's really interesting and
honestly i mean she looks cute no matter
what but she doesn't look like someone
who was knew the paparazzi was going to
be there i was um
i'm sure she was glad she was wearing a
mask because you can't see her face when
you were on maternity leave oh it was
when olivia wilde got served at those
custody papers during cinemacon and it
was like so awkward taylor strecker was
um
my co-host that day and we were just
talking about how like getting served is
so crazy and i asked her if she's ever
been served or whatever and she was like
no but i had to serve for her divorce
and she was like it was like you think a
lot about it you can choose where to do
it you don't want it if you care about
the person you don't want to embarrass
them like do it at work you know um and
she said it was like a really crazy
experience gotta serve someone
who's it gonna be i think bryce
i'm gonna serve streisand or charlie
puth
a cease and desist no literally like
cease and desist
for posting on tick tock emotional
distress no literally
so who knows what this lawsuit is
regarding i'm sure someone does but it's
just you know just more and at this saga
and i actually feel like this story
wouldn't you know it's another lawsuit
for erica james right honestly i'm
immune to them but the fact that she was
served publicly there's pictures and
videos that's the story yeah that's the
story but also i don't know i i'm i
think erica jane's at this place where
like
like at least for me i don't really care
like i fully believe now like she really
probably didn't know that much and like
maybe she had investigated like she
could figure it out herself but i don't
think she really cared that much about
what tom was doing for a living just
like was happy living her life and she's
bearing the brunt of everything because
tom is incoherent and lives in a home um
but my vibe now is like i really don't
care
like she's way past like the drama in my
opinion i'm sure yeah i feel like
troubles are far from over but oh yeah
but i feel like for her it's just like
what's another lawsuit you know she's
trying to spend
like another one
she's gonna spend a really long time in
court
in court
and it's going to be really expensive
yeah it's expensive to be here
yeah
it is
it's right don't even start it's okay
boys
are you ready for our next story
i
really am it seems as though the view
has selected their replacement for megan
mccain finally oh this is like jeopardy
i didn't even know we were still doing
this right this is like jeopardy except
and this is still a report it's not
confirmed they haven't announced it on
the show yet but page six seems to know
for certain that alyssa farah griffin
will be replacing megan mccain on the
view uh who the [ __ ] is that she was the
former uh communications director for
donald trump's white house
okay so conservative girling yep um
don't know who that is and again this is
who it is either and that's so much hype
after megan left like this is literally
mayan bialik like who cares yeah except
you knew miami and maybe if you watch of
you she's been one of the people who's
been in rotation they already replaced
her with that woman anna navarro right
but who would torture themselves and
watch the view enough to find out
so perhaps you know she did a good job
but i'm glad they made a choice yeah and
i felt like for a while they weren't
going to make a choice i thought they
already had
with anna navarro for some reason i
followed the view i think on tick tock
because they followed me and i was like
let me be respectful you know of whoopi
in the crow um so i see clips sometimes
and it's always that woman on a navarro
i literally thought she like i thought
this was done well she might be a host
but not the one replacing megan you know
she was definitely just like like a
frequent
temporary queen
but um
i guess she didn't do a good job because
she didn't get the job yeah and i also
feel like
this could have been like a really great
opportunity to make a splash you know
with like someone who's like big
polarizing yeah and at least for me
maybe because i don't know i've seen a
picture of her like no honestly i i
don't i don't know her no i never seen
i'm sorry to this woman i'm sorry to
this woman i don't know this woman but
good luck in the job you know the more
time that goes by the more megan shares
about her experience yeah and how awful
it was you know i
cannot imagine why anyone would want
that job obviously like it's an amazing
opportunity yada yada um and if you're
one of the other four women who i think
align more politically like it's
probably so much fun like we're all
ganging up on the other girl
i totally get why you would want to be
sunny or any of the other girls um i
cannot for the life me imagine why
anyone would want to be like the other
person um it sounds horrible and
everyone leaves like i don't see a
rotating chair for any of the other
women like right sunny and will be
they've been there forever right
joy
jinx so um i really hope this girl has
like you know a thick skin good mental
health i hope it's a really big paycheck
because there's honestly there's
probably a number that's like okay i
would do something like that for that
public humiliation on a daily basis
so i hope it's worth it
i probably don't think it is like
honestly no
but whatever i mean if she is the one
and she signed her contract then it was
enough to do this job yeah no i'm really
wishing her the best of luck to like
yikes
yikes girl i really good luck good
good luck and hopefully they'll make the
official announcement soon and i'm just
glad they made a choice yes the megan
stuff i find really interesting because
megan is conservative girly but she's
also just like
deeply um
connected in the political space so she
knew whoopi before they knew her parents
i believe she knew joy and now like the
vibe that she's putting out afterwards
is like joy was literally like horrible
to her what's so interesting is like
when it was all going down and you would
see clips from the show where like they
had a really bad day or they got into a
big fight and it was like oh my god how
could these people still be co-workers
how did they not hate each other then
like you would see megan go and watch
what happens live and she's like no i
love joy we have a mutual respect we
talked about it after the show and like
it's totally fine i'm like okay so it's
totally fine like these people just
bounce back from these things but now
when megan talks about it's like oh no
it really was a horribly toxic work
environment it looked it felt exactly
how it looked and
it's just yes because i used to think
i'm like you know megan is like you know
the only one who has a difference of
opinion but she every time she tweets
about it or talks on my drop inside
she's like that's just the job like i
love these women and we have different
beliefs and i was like yes i'm like
that's america baby like so mature and
now it's like actually there was
bullying harassment like everyone was
meeting to each other we all hated each
other and i was like damn like
because i i choose to believe in a world
where like people can have a difference
of opinions and still love and respect
one another right and like for a while
while megan was on there and like being
on watch happens live all the time
saying like it's just you know politics
we're still friends i was like yes like
this is proof and i feel like
like a couple of years ago when megan
was on the view and like she was making
news about like a moment between her and
whoopi we said how like that's the
honestly like a really cool thing about
the view is like that was meant to be i
think one of the points of the show it's
review and there are many points of view
and we're just going to have
conversations about that but like so
many people have written books after
their time on the view and it's like
it's actually not like that at all and i
don't think it's really ever been like
that no and i think especially in the
months since megan left it's now just
the one view right and it's just and
there's no one well we'll see we'll see
what happens what's her name uh alyssa
farah griffin we'll see what happens to
alyssa
yeah best of luck girlie best of luck
are you ready for a fifth and final
story which is a little random news but
i started following the new york post on
instagram and they post like all these
random news stories to their feed and i
thought this one would be fun to talk
man with eight arms climbs out of well
that he's lived in for 75 years stuff
like that but that's what the fifth and
final story is meant to be human
interest it's human interest so a woman
is advertising for a farmer to marry her
best friend okay
these two girlies gorgeous girls oh my
god beyond gorgeous wait
those are just regular girls regular
girls from new zealand one of them girls
from new zealand are really pretty yeah
one of them moved to uh farm country
and to marry a farmer who she loves and
she's living the farm tremor life yeah
this is literally a book right and she
has a friend named amber who wants to
live the farm life too like so they
could all be like four farmers together
going on date nights to the barn yeah
and amber wants a reason to like leave
the city and move to the king count
country region and i feel like we're
helping amber by putting this on the
show right now we're spreading and so
her friend liv is looking for a great
farmer to marry her friend amber so that
amber can move to the farm what kind of
where did lift put this like
advertisement on new zealand farming
facebook group i'm
literally not okay this is get you a
friend like liv and then liv posted
these photos of amber
she's literally so gorgeous if somebody
doesn't option this story into like a
hallmark lifetime movie honestly or like
a romantic comedy book i could cause
this is literally the book that i just
read it's two books but it's not about
farmers it's about two regular like
college grads who end up both marrying
like brad pitt like two different brad
pitts and it's like they live next door
to each other and it's so cute like the
first book the first book is about the
first girl and then the second group
book is about the girl who meets the
other movie star through the first girl
so this sounds like it could be that
like somebody needs to write a book
about this it's so cute it's so cute but
we also need the happily ever after so
if you are in new zealand in the farming
community ideally the king country
region why don't you message live and
get to know amber no and also okay i'm
like thinking about this being turned
into the movie because these girls are
so beautiful and they're australian they
should play themselves uh madison brown
from
kirby from dynasty like she needs to
play the one who needs the boyfriend
amber she looks just like her okay
perfect and let me see the other girl we
do we need to cast we want authentic
australian okay so this is amber with
her dog and she like clearly loves the
bucolic lifestyle and this is the two of
them that must be liv they're literally
both so beautiful i cannot believe this
isn't a story about models like yeah
those girls look like that and they're
not famous that's not what it's like
you're advertising for a boyfriend when
you look like that no there's no hope
for any of you go home
go home if this girl needs to put up a
billboard i've never seen a more
beautiful girl in my life and that's
just like a regular facebook photo it's
not an edited instagram page there's no
filter on it there's no like colors
there's no bisco no literally girls from
that part of the world are just and
amber was a bridesmaid at liv's wedding
here she is being amber's
i'm literally like upset like i put on
full glam today for this stupid show i
look like a rat you'll never be amber no
and i'll never be amber with no makeup
on at a vineyard you know no no that's
just your cross to bear and if someone
at the new york post is watching this
which i feel like you are because you're
always just like you know obsessed with
the toast um please follow up like we
need to find out what happens next
please follow up get in touch with liv
get a statement see what happens with
amber and toasters if you know any like
fine australian farmers
figure it out yeah check out this story
you could see liv's facebook page and
you could get involved in the process
and if any you know reality shows want
to go over there and film the process no
honestly i would be definitely watching
that i don't think i would watch because
i think a reality show like would
actually ruin it they'd set her up on
like fake dates i i want this to play
out however it plays out and then i
would like a really premium either movie
or book about it love it
we need um like no if we had a
production company
toast productions we need lucy score to
literally write this book we would send
pro toast productions out there and we
would make the movie it's like recently
if we had hello sunshine yeah yeah
making movies of books that she wants to
see into movies which we're talking
about
we're making stories real life stories
into books or in movies yeah
no hello sunshine needs to get on this
immediately yeah in collaboration with
toa studios yeah tnn
yeah
so those were the past five stories i
feel as though you absolutely needed to
know them you definitely needed to know
that last one warmed the cockles of my
heart
and we're not done yet so we've only
been in for 48 minutes you guys like
there's so much more to come so much
more because it's wednesday which means
to your toasters so
our weekly advice segment every
wednesday we do your toasters you can
write into us totally anonymously will
not blow up your spot and you could
write in about anything today we have
some cheating stuff we have some
boyfriend stuff we have some red flags
we have some friendship stuff you can
write into deertoasters gmail.com if you
need advice on anything we also do
unburden yourselves on monday so email
unburdenyourselves gmail.com if there's
something really embarrassing that you
did also for next week on monday
unburden yourselves we're doing like a
special anxiety
themed oh cute unburden yourself so over
the weekend if you guys have any really
embarrassing things that are giving you
terrible anxiety when you were drunk
right into unburdening yourselves at
gmail.com it's gonna be a really fun
segment brought to you by sprit
oh because monday is the spritz one year
anniversary that's crazy i know so it'll
be exciting what a year but the regular
deer toasters are brought to you by
modern fertility we're supposed to go to
the ob gyn once a year for our annual
checkups but checking in with our
fertility isn't usually a thing until
we're ready for kids but that's why
modern fertility was created it's an
easy and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick you mail it in with a
prepaid label you'll get easy and
personalized results within 10 days
you'll get insights into your hormone
levels your ovarian reserve which is
basically how many eggs you have
compared to other women your age and
other important fertility factors the
results go deep into what every hormone
means and you can also download the
results to review with your doctor for
next steps traditional testing for your
fertility can cost over a thousand
dollars but modern fertility gets you
the same exact information in a fraction
of the price if you go to
modernfertility.com toast you can get an
additional 20 off your test so the test
is 179
it's 199 but with our 20 off it's 179.
so they're offering our listeners 20 off
the test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast it means your
test will cost 179 dollars instead of
the thousands it could cost at your
doctor get 20 off your fertility test
when you go to modernfertility.com
toast that's modernfertility.com
toast great all right you ready for dear
toasters ready hi jackson claude my
queens
a few months ago i went on a date with a
guy who gave me major red flags but for
some ridiculous reason i decided to give
this guy another chance he invited
himself to my house and immediately upon
arrival asked why i didn't have dinner
ready
we ordered chinese and when the food
arrived he insisted that i make his
plate by dividing the plate into three
sections and delivering it to him as
we're eating he spilled on a shirt and
then proceeded to rip off his shirt and
asked me to launder
it
at this point i was cringing but
decided to launder the shirt as this man
was unhinged i retrieved the shirt from
the dryer as he walked to my bedroom i
told him to leave but he didn't
acknowledge me he got undressed and went
to bed i frantically called my friends
to help but this man was already naked
and passed out so i slept on the couch i
woke up to the sound of my shower
followed by this man asking me to make
him a coffee at this point i flipped out
and told him to leave flash forward to
today i am dating an incredible man who
asked me to spend the weekend at his
family's cabin i decided to do some
digging on facebook and that's when i
saw it my boyfriend's cousin is the
launder my shirt guy and i will be
spending the weekend with him what do i
do i already told my boyfriend the story
but never told him who the person was do
i tell him do i pretend i don't know his
cousin help sincerely how the hell did i
get here oh my god that's literally a
book
that is a book that is
fun and also scary yeah that was
starting to scare me right like getting
undressed and getting in your bed until
that point it was just him being a dick
but right no you told him to leave and
he went to sleep in your bed naked
honestly sounds like he might not have a
home that's what i was thinking too
anyways he probably spilled on purpose
so that he could get a fresh shirt get a
free meal and a place to stay oh my god
you should just be nicer to women and
women would just like let them stay at
his house their house for a few days and
use laundry and take a shower totally
but he's definitely by the way he's
definitely
was definitely at the time probably
homeless yeah because that's a thing
that men do they couch surf with women
yeah so they don't have to pay rent
there was that article in new york post
all those years ago about a guy who
hasn't lived in an apartment for a year
and has literally slept with different
women for like a few days at a time to
have a place to stay it was crazy crazy
but anyways in response to your question
tell your boyfriend that it was him like
you did nothing wrong so there's no
reason you're going to be feeling weird
all weekend and you don't want your
boyfriend to think you're feeling weird
about being with his family or that
you're not sure about the relationship
or that there's something else going on
just like honesty is the best policy you
have nothing to be ashamed of there's no
reason why you wouldn't share and nobody
knows the story no and he already knows
the story so now you could be like by
the way and it doesn't sound like you
you know you went on a date with his
cousin and now you're realizing his
cousin so you're going to tell him this
whole story it's like you already told
him about this crazy he didn't sleep
with him so like you have like there's
nothing weird there's nothing weird this
is so crystal clear this is so crazy
bizarre this is like one of those things
where it's like the world is so small
i'm so sorry that you had to experience
that and now you're like reliving it
because i'm sure it's horrifying but
definitely tell your boyfriend and also
ask if maybe at the time like maybe he
fell upon hard times just because i'm
curious yeah because it sounds like he
was using you for like
a hot meal a bed and a new shirt yeah
all right good luck with that let us i
would love an update on you all right
next up hello jax claude raisins
oh and i'm so glad that you wrote when
we have all four together and this is
from two girlies they wrote together
we are long time just like when a book
is written by two authors
we're such nerds
we are two longtime toasters and best
friends who need your help we have a
friend lynn and she's a part of our very
tech friend group that has been together
for most of our 20s and into our 30s we
are all very close but unfortunately
lynn can be really cheap at times
despite having one of the more lucrative
jobs of our friend group she also likes
to quote host parties we think mainly to
avoid the cost of an uber to get
anywhere else it's gotten to the point
where every time she quote hosts a party
the plan uh
the plans are solidified then shortly
before the event everyone in the group
is given specific items to bring whether
it's food drinks or both we started
realizing that we are all bringing the
entire party about 90 of the food slash
alcohol while she provides whatever
leftovers are currently in her pantry
like nuts or crackers while none of us
mind contributing and we never show up
to anywhere empty-handed we are starting
to feel taken advantage of because of
how disproportionate her contributions
are at her own party and she seems to
have no problem with it how do we make
her see the issue with this as she's
constantly inviting us over we are very
non-confrontational group of girls and
we like to keep the drama low but this
is getting impossible to ignore any
advice you can provide would be greatly
appreciated ps we will send a follow-up
you just need to give her a taste of her
own medicine you say parties at my house
this time lynn you're bringing the this
that and the other everyone else like
just do exactly what she's doing but
before she can do it i would also avoid
lin's house like the plague like the
next time she wants to host a party all
the girls should be like oh we already
decided we're going um bowling tonight
like meet us there at 10. yeah like do
not go to her give her a choice in this
situation she doesn't have choices yeah
it sounds like she's the only one with
like a little bit of balls in the group
so she's taking advantage of the fact
that you guys are low drama
non-confrontational and that's how
you're getting walked all over but she
is taking advantage of you guys if she
is not contributing
buying stuff for the party and just like
things that having it at her place is
contribution enough you know once in a
while it is yeah but you're literally
forbidden from going to her house that's
how you the fact that you keep going and
she keeps getting away with it is why
she keeps doing it
you just need to put the plans in the
chat hey was talking to jenny and we're
going to jenny's house this weekend um
i'm going to bring this if lynn you
could get that yeah felicia get that you
know
lynn felicia
jenny
i'm just i find it interesting like when
you make up names like what comes
those alicia is unique like really
different not like other names i don't
know what inspired these names this is
just how i'm seeing your group of
friends i love that i'm always like a
sarah or rachel i go biblical that's
true yeah you can never go wrong i don't
know where i pulled isaac jacob and
abraham i have to think maybe it might
be for books what was the name of the
girl who was having everyone over lin
lin
well actually they wrote lin manuel
miranda but i just abbreviated it
because i didn't want to it's like word
jumbo and i have a hard time reading
these your toasters as is yes but i did
appreciate their creativity and toasty
references
are you ready for a third and final this
one's pretty wild okay i'm ready hello
jackson claude blass and stress so far
these are clear cut
yes
sometimes you guys really confound me
right and we really don't know which
route to take but so far i feel like
it's been i'm 100 certain and i think
you probably will be certain about this
one too i love certainty i'm gonna try
and keep it short and simple because i
desperately need your help okay a year
ago i cheated on my boyfriend i got
blackout drunk with my best friend we
went back to her apartment and i hooked
up with her soon-to-be brother-in-law it
was a make-out and a five-second [ __ ]
before i ran away crying and went to bed
after which i told no one not even my
best friend but her fiance definitely
saw and was aware of what happened
a few months later i came clean to my
boyfriend and then to my best friend my
boyfriend and i decided to stay together
and i moved to texas to be with him we
started couples therapy and we are now
engaged my fiance wants nothing to do
with my best friend and her fiance
it reminds him of something traumatic to
say the least and he doesn't want the
fiance at our wedding he says that he
knew what was happening and clearly
disrespected him and he wants nothing to
do with him now my best friend says that
my fiance's manipulative and controlling
and refuses to even be my friend until
my fiance can get over it help a bride
in distress oh that's rough i know what
it reminds me of vanderpump rules no um
the moronic storyline in sex in the city
where um
carrie cheats on aiden with big and
obviously they break up and then her and
aidan get back together and she like
maintains her friendship with big big
comes to aiden's country house he calls
her all the time once she's like i want
you guys to be friends you literally
cheated on him with this guy that's
insane but that's not the same thing
because he she's not asking her fiance
to be okay with the guy that she the
brother the guy she cheated with they
never see the brother yeah yeah the
fiance is mad at the other friend's
fiance for like knowing what happened
and not telling him
but i don't think that's fair
um maybe that's something that you guys
need to talk about in like couples
counseling yes i mean it's definitely
probably embarrassing like to see them
around and have them at your wedding
knowing that they know what happened but
if he's able to forgive you it's not
fair for him to like place his anger on
this person that he knows like three
degrees removed and
i don't think he's being controlling or
manipulative i just think it's like
probably where he has placed all of his
anger about the situation and
that's
you need to work on like
working through that anger instead of
just like letting him blame them
honestly like i don't know if i agree
like
he's forgive he really only has to
forgive her
and he has and i don't think it's so
crazy that he doesn't like want to be
reminded they moved like he doesn't want
to be reminded yeah but this is her it's
embarrassing it's not fair for her
to have to like lose a friend
i don't know i like
she can't invite the girl to her wedding
and not invite her fiance for sure
fiance didn't do anything wrong
but you know i also need to know more
about your mans
because now your best friend is saying
that your
fiance is manipulative and controlling
is he or is that just her responding to
this issue or she's actually trying to
help you know she upset it if this
wasn't a thing right
okay so i chan i actually take it back i
actually don't think i have like good
advice here because honestly like i i'm
like a little bit sympathetic to the
person who got cheated on that's just me
like of course so my even if sometimes
it's like if you choose to forgive and
to move on then you really have to
forgive and move on but that's what
happens i think a lot of times with
couples who get back together after like
infidelity is they forgive but they
don't forget and they really like don't
forgive and they don't fully trust so
it's just more of like a slower
breakdown of the relationship as opposed
to like a full breakup but it sounds
like you guys are still in couple
therapy so i would unpack this thing
therapy yeah because this is
it's a quandary it's a quandary but i do
think like in order to for them to move
on from it like they really have to move
on and that includes the couple yeah and
being able to be reminded of it and
being okay it's not like it was the
fiance it was the fiance's brother right
oh my god if he was the
actual person no we would have goodbye
but that's what i was saying
that's
carrie is so [ __ ] wrong i just
recently watched that episode where like
you know big is having lady troubles and
he like confides in carrie and she's
away in the country and he was like can
i please come and she's like goes over
to aiden and it was like he's coming and
adam was like what like literally what
[ __ ] crazy like if you need any more
reason to understand like why carrie is
the quote watch like the three episodes
where she's back together with aiden and
they like zoom in on her friendship with
big the man who she literally had like a
weeks-long affair with the first time
she dated aiden it's so asinine also the
country houses in episodes in general
are just really unfavorable towards cats
yeah she's so so mean a brat a brat yeah
like literally he built that cabin with
his bare hands put in his own hot water
heater and she's complaining that she
has to go like okay stay in your little
apartment in the hot summer weekend
justice for suffern justice for aiden
completely like
literally if you could have ended up
like you know if you were carrie and you
were normal and not a [ __ ] and you had
your choice between aiden and big who
would you have chosen
because i think aiden is like more
handsome
the thing is i i
i i'm equally into both of them and i'm
not obsessed with either one of them no
but if you i want you to choose
let's break it down probably aiden
probably in because big like that whole
like chasing him around for 20 years
like that could never be me yeah i agree
like oh you love me and you want me and
you're wonderful and you're supportive
and you successful you build things you
no really the only thing
big had going from was his money because
honestly he wasn't that handsome and he
was a different he's handsome but it
sounds like he had this amazing
personality no aiden was like hot as
hell and like he's just like with all
the models and like yeah yeah like going
to movie premiere
yeah no you're right aidan is like
totally like husband dad material yeah
but and he was like really financially
stable like his business was taking off
like in the movie he's out in dubai not
like he's not successful no but big was
like big time banker big wig but they're
both businessmen beau yeah no i would go
aiden and like aiden had a dog so
obviously you could bring bryce
and a country house big right no and
like you know
it's it's a fixer-upper like get get
your hands dirty gary like put in your
own bathtub like what do you want
where's your sweat equity right right
so this is your toasters gmail.com if
you want to write in to see us um
that's our show um we're about to find
out if today's episode has any technical
issues but i'm looking at the camera i'm
looking at the podcast equipment i feel
like we might be in the clear so i don't
want to jinx it but um thank you guys so
much for your patience this week we
really appreciate it but we're getting
into a good space yeah tomorrow actually
might be like visually different
visually different workings we're gonna
move some things around we're
considering some things yeah please uh
just don't come from the couch like
don't be like yeah get rid of it no
don't don't come for the couch and be
like yikes
you know don't be that girl that's the
title of today's episode one more person
um thank you so much for listening to
the morning show similarly morning show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite at it no wait i keep
[ __ ] up thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the milan
morning show where we deliver the fast
stories you need to know every monday
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
video pass box all the places where we
listen to podcast find us the morning
toast leave a five star review about
beautiful stunning and smart we are have
an incredible hump day don't forget to
hump someone you love consensually and
we will see you tomorrow make it in crab
you guys make it in crab in crayon hump
day
bye bye